una volta dovevo andare nel magazzino e
me lo vedo l'itala porta aperta
il capo testa tipo urlando quanto
qualcuno non vedevo che era fortissimo
tutto arrabbiato entro
guardo con chi sta prendendo e c'era un
carrello ciao ragazzi spero se di tutti
bene è arrivato l'inverno è arrivato il
freddo e quindi sono arrivate anche
personalmente le serate a casa io sto
passando molto tempo a guardare film su
infiniti con il quale sto collaborando
mi sono visto recentemente entourage
come ammazzare il capo ii e mi sono
rivisto tipo per la millesima volta il
diavolo veste prada tra parentesi se
volete vederli pure voi potete farlo
tranquillamente su infiniti tv.it tra i
film che vi ho elencato naturalmente non
sono stati messi lì a casaccio perché
perché tutti e tre hanno come minimo
comune multiplo il tema di questa
puntata per questa puntata di vita
buttato ho deciso di chiamare
all'interno degli studios di casa mia un
grandissimo ospite che è stato molto
apprezzato dal pubblico che è il mio
fratello enrico ma che questa volta ha
deciso di farvi vedere non puoi andare
in scena così ma il fatto è che non li
asciugati col phon e avresti dovuto per
chi non conoscesse questo format vi
chiedo di mandarmi su facebook dei dm
vocali relativi al tema di questa
puntata e devo dire che questa volta ci
sono delle grandi chicche quindi direi
di partire subito ad ascoltarle
negozio e continuare a lavorare e
inutile dire tra domandato falcon heene
kakà si fa licenziato io sono il
terremoto è nel senso sì ma manda
affanculo il capo miseno vederci ancora
il tabù delle situazioni più
imbarazzanti è stato quando aveva
iniziato uno stage è una mia collega
arrivavano con un po particolare si
chiamava don cola di cognome e io ero di
enel con l'ufficio che stavo facendo
il compito che mi avevano affidato
quando sente urlare con una merda stava
chiamando solo la collega io non credo
il capo di una merda perde a madre
natura che è una merda perché non ha
cambiato ancora il cui pil cognome e poi
su per volare si fanno parte di me con
ha pure si abolivano vocale i vecchi
capi erano quelle da una macchina che va
in galera al regional 8 e chi può pensi
io stavolta per aiutarsi soltanto chi
non è rendere al negozio di un'immagine
tipo con cosa delle finestre mentre
gallino io perché altro dico meglio
zanzariere che dici 109 batteri della
dinamica di ben ali praticamente stava
pulendo la consu
[Risate]
non strillata cenerentola non capendo
questa lezione
vi abbiamo più ridere tanto perché parla
così una sera quando un signore mi ha
lasciato 36 euro di mancia e io
onestamente io li ho portati mi ha detto
realmente ti lasciano quella marcia solo
perché mi fai pena ma questa è una
persona da arrestare cioè motivare che
dice una cosa del genere
no questo è grave però invece per quanto
mi riguarda quando facevo il cameriere
mi sbottono lo chef in cucina dicendo
non si entra in cucina senza cappello
quando dovevamo portare le cose in
cucina e quindi una mia collega ci sono
fatti dei cappelli di carta pinocchio
prendete per il culo
il mio capo la quale ogni tanto lavabile
compito di svolgere delle roba assurde
peggio della peste trova chi può mettere
gigante di tanto degli annunci per
cercare la sua nuova domestica sono
annunci tipo senza famiglia senza casa
brutta massimo 26 anni e residenza
italiana patentata hanno auto in pratica
cerca un roi dopo i pedali che la cava
come troppo una donna single sulla
quarantina che non era bellissimo e mi
guardava in un modo come carnale
facendomi delle continue avance sul
posto di lavoro ad esempio una volta
temperato una matita
lei è venuto da me non opera una vera di
si blocca e mi fa che me la matita molto
lunga e appuntita sì sì questa è una
delle tasse ma che frase sessuale
scusami ragazze pensano senza ricorda
come fatto anche
[Risate]
allora il trentesimo compleanno del mio
capo è lui era fidanzato da tanto tempo
che una ragazza ma entrati in una
relazione grandissima con un'altra ed
entrambe le ragazze hanno deciso di
fargli una sorpresa presentandosi al
locale in cui lavoravamo tra cui una di
loro anche una bellissima torta che poi
è finita in faccia lui che quando si è
scoperto tutto quello che era successo
no questo era un capolavoro comunque da
vedere se il capo è operativo un atom ma
tu quindi allora ma anch'io mondiale
fare loro da morta inoltre carla il mio
canto volte mi fa e quindi io devo
continuare va la canzone pa per non
deluderlo canto anch'io come lei chi ha
come capo enrico papi lavorerà un caffè
all'italiana chiama carmine prestiti
internazionali ad essere meglio
accettato dalla società si fa chiamare
karmal in ebraico attivo in glories best
corro mi parlavi di dirmi una certa
persona il giorno dopo nera svizzera in
bagno
marin bagno sto facendo solite cose mi
chiamo così l'ingegnere tipo fantozzi
con la valera in bocca nel pentolone
fosse uno scritto l'ho mandato a [ __ ]
questo forse il mio commento preferito
giorno andato a mangiare a casa di mia
nonna lei arrabbiandosi come te lo so
quale motivo mi lanciava una ciabatta
torso io parando la pasta di nonno
[Risate]
giuseppe io ti adoro ragazzi sono
arrivati alla fine di questo video io
ringrazio con il cuore ogni volta tutte
le persone che mi mandano i messaggi sia
quelli che vedete invidiano poi un sacco
di altre che sono carinissima che poi
alla fine non riesco a infilare dentro
fateci sapere naturalmente quali sono
state le vostre esperienze con i vostri
capi iscrivete melo qua sotto mettete un
la xvi è piaciuto condividetelo
iscrivetevi fate tutte queste cose qui
noi ci vediamo naturalmente il prossimo
video ciao ragazzi grazie arriva esserci
stato comunque dopo pignorare
[Musica]